- Pour que jamais plus ne
s'éteigne la lumière des yeux
des femmes parce qu'el
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette-Comeau
Radio-Canada, Mon
Et je reçois maintenant
a été changée à jamais
par ce drame. Bonsoir, Nat
- Bonsoir.
- Donc, vous avez assisté
Quels sentiments vous habitent
après 32 ans, quand même
ce soir?
NATHALIE PROVOST, coporte-parole
de PolySeSouvient, survivant
c'est le sentiment de pas être
seule. Il y a beaucoup
de solitude dans tous ce qui
a entouré les événements
de Polytechnique dsasasasasasas,
une journée de pluie,
une températur o o o o on était
nombreux. Beaucoup avaient envie
d'être là, autour de nous,
et moi, ça metetetetetetetetetes
que les choses avancent
dans tout ce que représentent
les événements de Polytechnique.
Donc, c'était une gr
participation citoyenne
aujourd'hui.
- Et plusieurs des dignitaires
qui étaient là on parl
C'est important, ce devoir
de mémoire, encore auj,,,,,
pour vous?
des féminicides, on a beaucoup
parlé de ça au Québec,
mais il y en a partout
au Canada. Quand on voit
par arme, les morts qu'il y a eu
au Québec, mais qui ont
aussi dans d'autres grandes
villes du Canada, oui,
qui en
sont importants, parce que
ça nvavavavavavancer,
parce que ça nous oblige
à
- Oui, de voir qu'il y a encore
hein, quand on parle juste
des féminicides, par exemple,
18 cette année encore au Québec.
de notre vulnérabilité, ça parle
a été difficile, à quel point
une économie difficile, un m
les inégalités sociales,e qu'ile
des inégalités dans les rapports
homme-femme, donc, c'est
Sur le plan des féminicide,
je pense quand même que
si ça nous révolte tous
et auprès de nos prochespopopopi
ont besoin, femmes et hommes.
de toute la lutte pourun meillee
de tous les types d'armes,
à nos cr,r,r,r,r,r,r,r,
malgré des promesses qui
nous ont
en mai, mais... pas des
promesprprprprprprprprojets
de loi. La promesse électorale
fa
de le recevoir, contents
demamamamamamamamais
on a grand espoir qu'ils vont
la marchandise.
- Oui, vos relations n'étaient
pas si bonneé,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,é,ée
persona non grata, en fait.
Vous vouliez même pas le voir
à cet événement. Donc, qu'est-ce
qui dontntntntntntntntntntntntns
en campagne électorale.
Pour nous, particulière
pour PolySeSouvient parce quees.
C'est pas des promesses,
c'est des demandes h
D'abord, un rachat obligatoire
des armes de style d'ass
c'était un pas, mais pour quecet
permanente et qu'on voie
un vrai effet sur la sécurité
des Canadiens, il faut rachat
C'est pour ça qu'il était
àjojojojojojojojojojourd'hui.
Ils ont aussi promis de bannir
les chargeurs à grande capacité.
sont limités à cinq balles,maiss
limitée, elle, donc on enlève
avec un chargeur de grande
capacité. Et ils ont dit qu'ils
agiraient là-dessus aussi.
engagements fort importants
qu'ils ont pris, qui répondent
à nos demandes historiques.
dans le contrôle des armes à feu
sans voir tout le travail
qui reste à faire, notamment
Le jeu entre municipal d'abord,
provincial ensuite, pour nous,
c'est un jeu un peu stérile.
responsabilités appartiennent
au gouvernement fédéral,
et il faut qu'ils aillent
au bout de leur capacité.
engagements et tardé à agir.
- Tardé à agir et l'engagement
pour les armes de poing,
Ce qu'ils ont dit même
en campagne électorale,
c'est qu'ils étaient prêtsOn pen
moment de faire ça. On pense
au plan fédéral. On va continuer
le travail avec eux.
- Surtout quand on voit la
illégales, hein, des armes
dans les rues. On voit ce qui
se passe dans les rues de la
qui ont été impliqués danss s sà
et qui ont perdu la vie.
Vous, vous lc,c,c,c,c,c,c,c,c,c,
de ces armes dans les rues?
(soupir de Nathalie)
- Il y a plus d'armes, il y a
plus de morts par arme à feu
mais on n'est quand même pasili.
C'est très inquiétant et il faut
parce que si on le prend
dramatique. Et les conditions
sociales dans lesquelles on est,
c'est cellse-là qui m'effraient.
d'aller vers quelque chose
de dramatique. Agissons donc
rapidement, maintenant,
et d'autres pertes de vie.
Et il y a des moyens d'action.
Il y a des choses qui sont
échanger avec le gouvernement
fédéral pour qu'il puisse
aller jusqu'au bout,seseseseses,
la mairessse Plante, qui était
d'autres maires au Québec v v vr
dans ce sens-là, puis on pense
avancées. Mais c'est maintenant.
Il faut pas laisser dégénérer
à contrôler. C'est un marchéquis
la couverture. Le marché
La problématique est beaucoup
plus complexe qu'en 1989.
Ça nous effraie.
quatre projectiles,
faut-il le rappeler.
- Oui.
- Nathalie Provost,
merci beaucoup d'être pass
et d'avoir partagé ce moment
- Merci de m'accueillir. Merci